welcome back our next presenter has done
Shakespeare no I mean in the last movie
she actually did Shakespeare
I'm cracking myself up it's okay y'all
look a child she is the reason that
Shakespeare fell in love
please welcome Best Actress nominee and
sweet kid Gwyneth Paltrow
to be or not to be
will there be candlelight or chandeliers
satin or velvet will the decor be
cluttered or clean such decisions are
the province of art directors who are
responsible for the overall look of a
film this year the nominees for best
achievement in art direction are
in Elizabeth the religious authority and
the power of the throne are captured in
striking art direction by John Mayer and
the set decoration of Peter how--it in
Pleasantville a black and white world is
transformed by color with the art
direction of Jenin upper wall and the
set decoration of J Hart in Saving
Private Ryan the destruction and
devastation of World War 2 were
portrayed most graphically by the art
direction of Tom Sanders and the set
decoration of Lisa Dean Cavanaugh in
Shakespeare in Love the Elizabethan era
of the bard is recreated most
affectionately by the art direction of
Martin childs and the set decoration of
jail quarter
and in what dreams may come the heavenly
vision of life in the hereafter is
majestically created by the art
direction of Eugenio Zanetti and the set
decoration of Cindy car and the Oscar
goes to
Martin child's for six
this is the first officer for Martin
childs and Jill quartiere whose combined
credits include mrs. Brown and much ado
about nothing
oh boy I made notes this is an honor
isn't it we had a lot of fun making this
movie and we'd love to thank the art
department my cragit Frannie Bennett
Steve Lawrence and all the other heroes
all the other Shakespeare O's and the
Evans and his brilliant team of
craftsmen location management Rachel
Neil Jill Duggar and Danny and Kevin and
the props boys Oh Judi Dench for her
wonderful news that the Rose Theater
will survive the set is being rebuilt
beam by beam and it's gonna last forever
this time Oh wrap up the asteroids
coming Elaine and Richards traitorix
and the academy for giving us this
fantastic thing
ladies and gentlemen Captain Picard of
the Starship Enterprise
mr. Patrick Stewart
this year the tumultuous
sixteenth century proved fertile ground
for filmmakers as evidenced by the first
two of our five nominated films for Best
Picture Elizabeth and Shakespeare in
love in the first we witness the rise to
power of the young woman who takes over
a realm debilitated by years of
religious strife and fashions it into
the Western world's most powerful nation
it's an inspiring portrait of the first
British sovereign named Elizabeth and in
the second of our nominated films
Shakespeare in Love Queen Elizabeth is
one of the young women will Shakespeare
tries to please it's an uproarious tale
of the bards quest to find his muse and
the paralyzing case of writer's block
and create a hit show here are Elizabeth
and Shakespeare in love